ladies and gentlemen nevada governor
steve sisilak
good evening in normal times i would be
addressing you tonight in this
legislative chamber
assembled in front of our constitutional
officers elected officials
supreme court justices and other guests
all know too well these are not normal
times
every nevadan has been impacted by the
covet outbreak
whether you've lost the job had to learn
from home
missed a graduation grappled with
keeping your small business open
or been unable to visit family for
birthdays and holidays
or in a hospital room this disease has
touched us all
and the truth is we still have a ways to
go but i know this
nevadans are battle born we face our
challenges head on
and we will get through this difficult
time together
because the state of our state is
determined resilient
and strong two years ago i came before
all of you for my first state of the
state address
i laid out a vision for what we could
accomplish and i'm proud of what we were
able to achieve working with state
lawmakers
from both parties who are watching
tonight
we gave raises to our teachers and
provided record funding to our schools
we passed sweeping health care
legislation to end surprise emergency
room billing
we outlawed insurance companies from
dropping people with pre-existing
conditions
we implemented nevada's first ever state
climate strategy
to expand the use of renewables and
decrease our dependence on fossil fuels
unemployment was low business was
buzzing and consumer confidence was at a
record high
and then on march 5th 2020 nevada got
its first case of covet 19.
shortly after we had five cases
which quickly turned into 15. then 100.
as of friday january 15th nevada had
over a quarter of a million
cases and over 3 700 nevadans
have lost their lives that's 3 700
families grappling with the loss of a
loved one
in that time we were faced with
excruciating choices that continue today
as we remain under a state of emergency
throughout this crisis we have worked
hard to balance
public health while doing everything we
can to keep the economy afloat
and our businesses open but the fact
remains
that our state and our people have
suffered in ways none of us could have
imagined a year ago
and let me tell you not a day goes by
that i don't think about the many
sacrifices
so many of you are making the challenges
are unprecedented
we have so much to fix but we are
forging
a new path forward tonight you will hear
about my priorities
and my plans to achieve them to win the
battle against covet 19
and vaccinate our people to get all our
students back in the classroom
and provide teachers with the tools they
need to do their job
to get our economy back on its feet and
our people back to work
and to look ahead to what's next
infrastructure
green energy jobs help for small
businesses
and the other engines of growth that
will provide new opportunities for our
people
through these historically challenging
times we've leaned on the most resilient
of nevadans
the heroes that helped us get through
the doctors
nurses caregivers faith leaders
public employees educators the nevada
national guard
and the many others working on the front
lines of this crisis over the last 10
months
that includes all of those caring for
our veterans throughout nevada
who have served our country they've been
showing up
putting themselves at risk every day to
make sure the state can move forward
there are people like dr jacob keeperman
in reno who joins us here tonight
governor i'm at renown medical center in
reno
the team here is incredible the nurses
doctors respiratory therapists
pharmacists housekeepers and the
countless others who all come nevada
home
who are working around the clock to
fight coven 19
this disease is relentless but with the
vaccine here
there is now hope but we can't let our
guard down
and you're wearing masks washing hands
and social distancing
and when your turn comes everyone must
get the vaccine
we can get through this together but
only if all of us do our part
so governor we are here with you to
continue fighting this fight
it's because of people like dr keeperman
that i am optimistic about our future
and on behalf of the state of nevada i
want to say thank you
from the bottom of my heart early in our
response with no playbook for this
historic crisis
nevada's public and private sector is
mobilized to fight this deadly virus
from local government and state agencies
to the response
relief and recovery task force chaired
by jim murran
and made up of business leaders from
across the state
partners rolled up their sleeves and got
to work
for example the nevada department of
agriculture worked to make sure nevadans
didn't go hungry
by providing over 16 million pounds of
food across the state
serving approximately 250 000
individuals per month
business and education leaders work to
bridge the digital divide
for our students by creating connecting
kids envy
in august approximately 80 percent of
nevada students
didn't have the device or connectivity
they needed to participate in distance
learning
as of the start of this month every
student participating in online learning
has at home access to the internet and
the computer to do their
work to keep people in their homes
millions of dollars were put into state
and local rental assistance programs
and an eviction mediation program was
created by chief justice jim hardesty
and housing advocates the nevada
national guard
under the leadership of major general
andra berry
embarked on the largest and lengthiest
state activation in nevada history
stepping up as the heroes we all need in
this moment of crisis
labs across the state increased testing
operations to record
record levels over 2.3 million covid19
molecular tests
thus far in 2019 labs in nevada
reported a total of approximately 300
000 lab results
for all diseases the increase is
staggering
but the truth still remains while heroes
like dr mark pandori
director of the nevada state public
health lab located at the university of
vatarino
have held nevada scale up our resources
so we can process
thousands of covid tests a day we as
nevadans
are the only ones who control how many
of those test results
come back negative while we are awaiting
the full benefit of the vaccine
we have to be united in our statewide
effort to slow and stop the spread of
this virus
by wearing masks avoiding gatherings and
protecting each other
we must remain vigilant our greatest
challenge now
is running the largest vaccination
campaign in history
despite lack of resources and
coordination from the federal government
we have pushed forward and to date we
have administered over 100 000
initial and secondary doses of the
vaccine and as we await more vaccines
for the state
we are ramping up our distribution
efforts our immunization team
the nevada national guard and division
of emergency management
are working with our local partners to
get more shots in the arms of nevadans
we are expanding our vaccination
workforce to include
ems providers medical assistants
pharmacy techs
dentists veterinarians and more a
vaccination mega site at cashman field
in las vegas
and we are coordinating with the private
sector including our resort properties
to have even more vaccination sites as
their supply ramps up
we are working with private health
providers like renown in washoe county
to distribute vaccine to local residents
who are not typically
their patients again let me assure all
of you
every part of government is focused on
vaccinating nevadans
anyone who tells you that covid night
public health crisis
is wrong it's also an economic crisis
and a fiscal crisis
it has impacted nevada's ability to feed
themselves and their kids
to keep the lights on to keep a roof
over their heads
to earn a paycheck and keep the benefits
that allow them access to health care
in our first months of the pandemic more
than 250
000 nevadans were laid off it was
devastating
you know the truth we're dependent on
hospitality for a big part of our
economy
and when travel stops hotel rooms go
empty
when showrooms close and our convention
business and tourism shuts down
it hits our state harder than any state
in the nation
that makes me more determined than ever
to get our world-leading hospitality
industry
open and our workers back on the job but
that's not enough
we need to expand our economy to other
world-leading industries
that can create new jobs and new
opportunities
for our people and everyone needs to
remember
it's not just big business that have
been hit hard our small businesses have
suffered
and they account for almost half of all
the jobs in our state
i've been amazed at the grit and
determination of so many small business
employees and owners
across nevada as they have worked to get
throughout this pandemic
people like trina giles who owns grits
cafe in las vegas
governor welcome to grits cafe
what a crazy year 2020
was we've been in business for over a
decade now
and this is by far the most
trying year in business but we're
getting through it
and we'll continue to strive and thrive
to provide a great service for our food
and a sense of normalcy for our
customers
when the pandemic first hit i was a
nervous wreck i didn't know what to do
but we found strength in our community
through their support as well as through
in their assistance and i'm so grateful
for that thank you trina
that's why in october i joined state
treasurer zach conan
and the governor's office of economic
development to launch a small business
assistance program
that has been providing up to ten
thousand dollars in emergency grant
funding to businesses
like trina's this funding has helped
small businesses keep their doors open
and their employees paid throughout this
difficult time
the response has been overwhelming and
so far we've provided 50
million dollars to small businesses
across state and nevada
but we need to do more that's why
tonight i am announcing an additional
50 million dollars in my budget for this
program which is vital for small
businesses
i'm asking the legislature as one of
their first items of business to get
this done
additionally our own lieutenant governor
kate marshall will be working to create
a small business advocacy center
to be a one-stop location to help small
businesses take advantage
of the resources that exist and help
them cut through the red tape
and as i said before it's not enough to
just aim for a full reopening of our
current economy
we must look forward to the kind of
economy that will let our state prosper
in the future
and create opportunity for all nevadans
so let me share with you five
initiatives
that will help propel us forward first
the new energy economy
nevada is at the geographical center of
energy transmission
for the western u.s and has an
opportunity to become to energy
what wall street is the finest or with
silicon valley is the technology
nevada is already a leader in renewable
energy
generating billions of dollars in
investment and employing tens of
thousands of our people
now we're perfectly poised to lead the
world in energy storage
to reach these ends i will work with
senator chris brooks
and the legislature to pass a bold
energy bill
establishing our commitment to increase
transmission
coverage and distribution of all forms
of clean energy
more importantly passing this bill will
create good paying construction jobs
starting this year
and helping in our fight against climate
change this bill will attract and
develop a variety of new industries
including electric vehicle
infrastructure component manufacturing
and lithium mining lithium is a primary
ingredient in electricity storage
and guess what nevada is home to the
most accessible lithium reserves in
north america
second i'm proposing the creation of
innovation zones in nevada
new companies creating groundbreaking
technologies
can come to nevada to develop their
industries this will be done without
tax abatements or public financing
following the passage of my innovation
zone legislation
blockchains llc has committed to make an
unprecedented investment in our state to
create a smart city in northern nevada
that would fully run on blockchain
technology
making nevada the epicenter of this
emerging industry
and creating the high-paying jobs and
revenue that go with it
let me also say that there are other
exciting innovations taking place
throughout the state
for example unity physicists are leading
the way
in breakthrough super conductivity
research this technology allows for
transmission of energy across
long distances without energy loss and
provides
huge commercialization and job
opportunities
while helping solve our energy and
climate challenges
the department of energy calls us
breakthrough the holy grail
of energy efficiency third preparing our
workforce for the new nevada economy
nevada has never experienced an economic
recovery challenge
as great as one it faces now many of the
jobs lost during the pandemic will not
come back
as businesses move towards automation
job training and retraining our
displaced workforce as well as
connecting nevada workers
with remote working opportunity and
emerging industries will be key to the
state's economic future
to achieve this goal i will be creating
the nevada job force
i will be calling on some of nevada's
leading companies to fund
design and implement training programs
to prepare and qualify employees
for these jobs in addition we need to
recognize that our community colleges
will play an even bigger role in
workforce training
that's why i'll be asking the
legislature to work with the nevada
system of higher education
over the next two years to develop a
framework
transitioning nevada's community
colleges into a new independent
authority
that will focus on making nevadans jobs
ready
community colleges together with union
apprenticeship programs
are critical elements in building
nevada's workforce and economic future
the kovit 19 pandemic has also changed
the way we work
with remote work opportunities doubling
by 2025.
nevada must be ready to take advantage
of this trend which is why i am
establishing the new
remote work resource center to connect
nevada workers with job opportunities
across the globe fourth building our
infrastructure
infrastructure creates real jobs for
real people
it will allow us to put hundreds of
millions of dollars
into our economy capital projects not
only create
high-paying construction and development
jobs
now but those infrastructure
improvements serve as the building
blocks for our state's economic
expansion
for decades to come the budget i
unveiled yesterday
includes 75 million dollars for capital
future improvement projects that will be
used to launch the state infrastructure
bank
so we can leverage outside capital to
fund important infrastructure projects
like rural broadband
renewable energy and road improvements
i'm also calling on state agencies and
local governments
to fast-track billions of dollars of
infrastructure projects
that haven't been started after we move
these projects from the list
of things that we need to do to the list
of the things that we
are doing the more nevadans we can put
to work
fifth making government work better
well public employees at every level of
government worked around the clock to
deal with the impact of the pandemic
we found that many of our government
systems were out of date
and overwhelmed we need to fix them this
was painfully apparent with our
unemployment insurance system
the division was hit by unprecedented
volume
going from handling 20 000 claims a week
to 370
000 claims a week a 20-fold increase
that increase created delays that caused
real hardship for families
by august there were 243 000 claims
waiting to be verified in order to
prevent fraud
fraud that would have cost businesses
and taxpayers tens of millions of
dollars
today the original backlog has been
reduced by 95 percent
we now have more staff and improved
systems to reduce the backlog
completely i want to thank speaker
barbara buckley
who chaired a rapid response strike
force and lissa cafferetta
acting director of dieter for their
extraordinary service addressing this
problem
however our computer infrastructure is
still outdated
and our systems can be improved i'm
recommending to the legislature
that we work together to modernize and
utilize
private sector expertise to help
nevadans in need
more broadly we need to recover the
federal funding dollars
that rightfully belong to nevadans my
goal is to increase nevada's share of
federal grants by a hundred million
dollars over the next two years and by
500 million
annually by 2026. now i'll be working
with assemblywoman danielle monroe
monreal
in our federal delegation to do just
that better systems
modernization private sector help more
federal dollars
that's a big part of the path forward
thanks state treasurer zach conan and
the governor's office of economic
development and countless others
who've helped develop this ambitious
economic plan
once implemented it will create thirty
thousand jobs in the short term
over the next decade it will create a
hundred and seventy thousand
construction and development jobs
and over a hundred and sixty five
thousand permanent jobs i believe in
this state
and in our future we will support our
current industries like tourism
while developing new industries
embracing innovation
workforce training investing in
infrastructure to create more robust
and sustainable economy and we will
emerge
stronger from this pandemic and lead the
nation in jobs
and opportunity now i'd like to talk to
you about the state budget
i will be honest putting together a
budget for the next two years is hard
enough in the good times
and even more difficult during a state
of emergency
analysts and economists have different
projections markets are volatile
business is uncertain and so this budget
reflects the emergency we are currently
in
just like your family the state will
take a responsible approach that
reflects our reality
today the fact is the state's financial
situation has improved slightly in the
past few months
the economic forum's december revenue
projection for the next biennium
is 8.5 billion dollars which is 418
million more than was projected in june
of 2020 at the time significant budget
cuts were made during the special
session
for perspective prior to the pandemic
projections were indicating we'd have
nine billion to spend in this budget
we are in an improved yet still
difficult position
the improvements in our fiscal situation
are the result of decisions we've made
over the last 10 months
where we worked hard to strike a balance
between protecting public health
and also protecting our fragile economy
here are a few important items i want to
tell you about the budget
participating general fund revenue of
4.1 billion dollars in fiscal year 2022
nearly 9 less than the previous year to
avoid even deeper cuts i'm proposing the
use of nearly 100 million dollars
from the state's existing rainy day fund
if our current situation isn't
considered a downpour
i can't imagine what would be this
budget reflects 187.2 million less
than the previous budget including the
elimination
of 152 vacant state positions over the
next two years
the kovit 19 pandemic and the unknown
economic impact required to state
employees to do more with less
including required furloughs for the
second half of fiscal year 2021.
my recommended budget will not include a
continuation of the furloughs
into the next biennium my budget also
prioritizes the health and well-being of
state employees
and their health benefits in the time
when health is wealth
while this budget makes tough reductions
it also contains smart investments in
the essential priorities i outlined
earlier
including restoring nearly 40 million
dollars in funding for preschool
415 million dollars dedicated for
construction
maintenance planning and economic
development
projects that will create thousands of
jobs in order to stop
talking about our doctor shortage and
actually start doing something about it
i'm proposing a 25 million dollar
one-shot expenditure
to help complete the unlv medical school
building
a school could generate as many as 16
000 jobs over the next ten years finally
in the time when one in four nevadans
are enrolled in medicaid
access to quality health care is
critically important to the public and
economic health of our state
during the 31st special session when
things look very
bleak the legislature was forced to make
six percent cuts to medicaid rights
and reduce neonatal intensive care unit
hospital service rights
to the efforts we've made our revenue
never went as low as our worst
projections and that is why my
recommended budget
calls on the legislature to restore the
rate reductions
to support nevada families and providers
i look forward to working with the
legislature to adjust this budget
and make responsible revisions i am
hopeful that
long overdue federal support to state
and local governments
will be delivered in the coming months
that support is critical
and it is outrageous that it hasn't
arrived already
this will be a dynamic process but an
important one
as we work to recover educate our kids
promote justice and equality and most
importantly now
protect the health of our people i look
forward to signing legislation that
creates jobs
saves the state money and improves
outcomes
that's what nevadans expect us to focus
on and that's what they deserve
to all the parents students and
educators out there i know this has been
a particularly tough time
none of us have ever faced anything like
covid19
just ask juliana airtube nevada's
teacher of the year who joins us tonight
thank you governor sislek it's an honor
to be here with you tonight
this year has been unlike any other for
teachers for students and for families
switching from face-to-face instruction
to remote instruction and hybrid
instruction has been a challenge for
our state it's really important to
acknowledge everybody who works in a
school from the cafeteria workers to the
custodians
our teacher assistants our
administration our front office
workers who know the families very very
well and have been amazingly
supportive in just making sure our kids
are connected
we are all so excited to get back to
normal i think about the day where my
students are going to come in i'm
going to give them great big hugs and
that brings me a lot of joy and it gives
me
resolve to get through these difficult
times we
absolutely cannot wait for that day to
come and we just send a lot of gratitude
to
family friends to kids for just doing
the absolute best
thank you julianna it is easy to forget
what life was like
before masks and social distancing i
want to pause for a moment and take this
opportunity to give a big
shout out to those who educate our young
people
nevada educators deserve credit for
handling the adjustments needed
to educate our kids while keeping
everyone healthy
and safe when our school shifted from
in-person learning
to virtual or online learning our
business people gained a new
appreciation for the valuable role
schools play
helping to keep our economy humming and
one other thing
that became even more apparent covet 19
has exacerbated educational inequities
further expanding the gap between the
haves and have nots
on top of that the lack of access to
in-person learning
has resulted in an increase in mental
and behavioral health problems for our
youth
it's unacceptable it's harmful to our
children and we need
to fix it the disparities in equities
that became so obvious
not just in education but in all facets
of our society
are important work that this legislature
and all nevadans must take on
i want to take a moment to recognize
senator joe neal
who is a true champion for social
justice for quality
and opportunity and held us all to
account in the work we do here
and in our state we've lost a powerful
voice
in nevada as many of you know
i have not been quiet about my urgent
desire to see children return to
in-person learning
because we will not recover as a state
if we leave our children behind
i will do whatever it takes to get our
students back in the classroom
that's why we've worked to supply ppe
ensure rapid testing was made available
to all school districts
and now prioritize our educators for
vaccines
with a new infusion of federal funds i
will continue to work with state
superintendent joan eber
local leaders to finish the job and get
all of our kids
in every area of the state return to
in-person
learning that's the immediate priority
but you also need to look at solving the
long-standing challenges
facing our schools two years ago in the
2019 legislative session
we began the process of modernizing
nevada's 53-year-old education
funding formula we took a significant
step in the right direction with the
creation
of the pupil-centered funding plan
education funding should be allocated to
meet
each student's learning needs the dollar
should follow the students
rather than being connected to the
districts or the schools
to accomplish this we established the
commission on school funding
including parents educators and
financial experts
the nevada department of education has
been working with the commission to
promote equity
transparency accountability and
flexibility in our school funding
approach
in light of this emergency budget i'm
recommending a phased approach to
implementing this plan that begins
during the 2021-23 biennium
with only state revenues followed by
phase two
in the next biennium that will include
both state and local revenues
this phased-in approach will allow
school districts to manage resources to
meet the needs of their communities
my budget also ensures marijuana tax
dollars will continue to fund education
to ensure districts can meet the needs
of students during the pandemic and
beyond
i would like to close tonight with two
personal thoughts
first i want to thank my family for
their unending support my mother mary
and my two daughters carly and ashley
and of course
first lady kathy sislek we recently
celebrated our two-year anniversary
and it allowed me to reflect on what a
lucky man i am for having her by my side
during one of the most difficult years
in nevada's history
kathy thank you second
i want to address the division and
polarization that is gripping our risk
it has to end it's breaking down trust
in our institutions
and threatening our ability to solve
problems we face
this is america this is nevada
and we need to pull together tonight
i've asked leaders from both parties to
join me
we don't always agree but when it comes
to the big challenges that we have faced
in our state
the economic recession one october and
now the pandemic
we work together for a stronger nevada
we're going to have our differences and
talk about them loudly but what we must
do
is come together as nevadans to defeat
this pandemic and rebuild our economy
together as one nevada we can beat the
pandemic
get our kids back in school rebuild our
economy
and achieve true equal justice and
opportunities
covet has challenged everyone we know
and everything we are
all nevada must unite and fight together
as we always have
hello nevada nevadans always rally in
difficult times
and now we must be stronger than we've
ever been come on nevada
let's show that the nevada family is
stronger than ever
thank you my friends now i'm asking all
nevadans to join me
in giving thanks to the over 200 nevada
national guardsmen
currently on duty in washington dc
nevada
we can do this we are determined we are
resilient
and we are strong speaker fryerson thank
you for hosting us in the nevada
assembly chambers today
thank you all god bless you and let's
get back to work